it is time for this week's pet project
lori aaron
joins us from the nspca brought along
someone who
needs a good and safe home i love the
name of this cat
beefcake he is
but he's also really okay so beefcake is
a perfect name for this guy
he's a beautiful buck-colored cat as you
can see
very lovable i mean you have this cat at
home really who needs a boyfriend
he's four years old he does have fib
kendall which
uh which is why we recommend that he's
either on his own or he's with other
cats with
fib and can still have a normal lifespan
and
today's a perfect day to adopt cats like
beefcake because you know
it is cenco d meow at nevada today you
know what
i get accused of bad puns and dad jokes
all the time and then you step
in with that i don't know what we should
do with that hey but i i feel i feel
like i should know what fib is but
fill me in sure fiv is short for feline
immunodeficiency virus it
is um an immune virus similar to
hiv in humans but it does still can have
cats with fiv
can still have a normal lifespan you
just have to watch for the secondary
infections and
there still are plenty fib cats that
live with non-fib cats but we recommend
that
they're either on their own or they're
with other cats with fib
meantime you invite people to come make
an appointment and then come down and
meet these pets they can eat beefcake
and any of the other animals that are up
for adoption there
see if they gel with their families and
perhaps even their other pets
absolutely go to nevadaspc.org and make
an adoption appointment
and we have adoption conference that can
talk to you so that these wonderful cats
like wheat cake
are a perfect fit for you and your
family beefcake was very active in this
segment he was not
too keen on just staying still for this
i will say that he is a lover though not
a fighter so he is
active but it's all about love today all
right lori it's great seeing you
if you're interested in adopting a pet
as we said you can go to the website
nevadaspca.org or call that phone number
702-873-7722